un escenario post apocalíptico es como
se ve la costa de cedeño en Honduras
debido al aumento del nivel del mar
casas y negocios están literalmente de
ruidos y sus habitantes en su mayoría
Pescadores ven como el mar se apodera de
la costa
ya otra vez se mete el mar ya tenemos
que desalojar acá tenemos que ver para
dónde irnos antes habían manadas de
delfines habían tiburones se acaban de
espadas meros de quintal en delante
ahora ya todo se ha perdido por la
deforestación de la flora y fauna el
océano se ha tragado casi por completo
los manglares que protegen la costa y
sirven de viveros y zonas de casa para
crustáceos moluscos y otras especies
marinas el rápido aumento del nivel del
mar no les da tiempo de adaptarse la ong
codefagolf comité para la defensa y el
desarrollo de la flora y la fauna del
Golfo de Fonseca desarrolla un proyecto
aún En fase de planificación para
mejorar las protecciones contra el
oleaje costero y reforestar el manglar
es el el de reclutamiento de los de los
glaciares verdad que eso está aumentando
el el caudal podríamos así decir del mar
y está provocando la pérdida de playa
según el grupo intergubernamental de
expertos sobre el cambio climático
el nivel del mar aumentó entre 15 y 25
centímetros entre 1900 y 2018 por lo que
todos los manglares podrían desaparecer
en los próximos 100 años las costas
atlántica y pacífica de Centroamérica
son algunas de las más amenazadas por el
calentamiento de la Tierra